in order to eliminate labor exploitation
we must continue working at improving
worker conditions and job quality in the
broader sense both in the member states
of destination and origin and to promote
awareness needed to create a climate of
zero tolerance of several labor
expectations it is blatantly
unacceptable that women and men are
being exploited in the labor market and
trafficked into as well as within day
you and I think this is what we also
need to remember we're talking about EU
nationals and non-eu nationals and their
traffic to supply unpaid or very low
paid work and services without receiving
any rewards while being kept in
conditions contrary to human dignity it
is unacceptable that there are victims
who fall within the cracks of the legal
system we need to use the EU directive
to move in a direction to increase
protection for victims but also increase
prosecution for this very serious crime
we need to see not only the victims that
our primary concern I spent all my
speech talking about victims but whole
profits from these people we need to
follow this money it's important to keep
an open mind that exploitation can occur
in many many sectors in many many areas
of the economy it is perhaps one of the
most significant findings of this
research that there is a lack of
comprehensive and effective monitoring
for situations of labour exploitation of
foreign workers the five main
conclusions we would draw from the
findings are these we first need to
strengthen
and reinforce the criminal law framework
that protects the rights of workers
against severely exploitation we
secondly need to improve workplace
inspections we need to empower victims
we need to encourage victims to report
in the end we need to create a climate
of zero tolerance for
severely exploitation in our societies
and in the end it is important to
realize that condo consumers can make a
difference we believe that there should
be a right of consumers to know whether
what they purchase has been produced
including or not including severe
exploitation of the workers we think
that in addition to the state the social
partners namely the unions the trade
unions and the employer organizations
have an important important role to play
in preventing and tackling the issue of
labor exploitation but also in
respecting and creating decent work in
the formal economy the report makes a
very crucial recommendation which is
almost a thinker the prerequisite of all
the work in this area and it is that all
public authorities be them the label
inspector eats at the police or
immigration officials all these
authorities should prioritize the
protection of fundamental rights of
victims of severe labor exploitation
over considerations of over immigration
control or other considerations of
public order today's legislation is
faking is pretending that the labor will
black market does not exist this
pretending is not going to improve the
situation in the country it's going to
worsen it so we need a regulation at the
European level that covers all workers
we need a strong and effective labor
inspection authorities the labor
inspection should be based on workers
rights and focused on identifying
exploitative situations rather than on
enforcing Texas and social security
contributions as it is currently the
case in Germany the victims of
exploitation afraid to report to the
authorities because
they don't want to lose that job and as
well they are so afraid to to to be
deported to their home country and
the top the top answer week we can give
is the one of compensation no it should
be clear that whoever is being exploited
deserves the compensation for the work
he has done its key first of all that
practitioners involved in the criminal
justice system and
recognize that these are victims of
crime if
it's criminalized in the in the
countries they worked on it work and
also treat them as such so the key to
this we believe is training the new
forced labor protocol is really putting
emphasis on the fact that victims are
workers most victims of forced labor
have initially consented to the
recruitment into their employment and
they are first of all workers often as
we are seeing in this report migrant
workers
these people really need to be empowered
and the ILO protocol call for measures
to ensure that those victims have really
access to remedies as was really
mentioned by everyone
specifically independent of their legal
status we must introduce new procedures
for legal entry into the European Union
this is the best way to neutralize the
power of employers to reduce the slavery
irregular migrants searching for a job
what is the bedrock commitment that we
would like to see put in place to help
address this kind of exploitation for us
and a number of our companies and others
we work with and I'll come to that it's
the import employer pays principle we
have legislation it's clearly not enough
we have resources but clearly not enough
or not focused enough and coming back to
that lack of public concern I think one
of the things that I think are needed is
this awareness ladies and gentlemen
despite the difficulty there's a lot
that can be done to change the situation
please allow me to highlight three lines
of action for a proposed first effective
monitoring I think everybody said that
through systematic and expert
inspections second effective
cross-border cooperation is needed to
enter define and resolve cases that
we've involved a number of countries
which is often the case in
subcontracting work or hanging through
labour brokers third certification one
proposal from X is the introduction of
certification system similar to that
used by filtrate international
accreditation which is its own words
aims to secure a better deal to for
farmers and workers
you